chacune est ce que vous êtes prêts pour
une interview psy
vous êtes désespérant michel film qu'est
ce que vous êtes mito un petit peu
mégalo énormément définition on peut pas
l'être un peu parano en septembre
dernier peut-être passé la bd les
plantes y est maso ça dépend avec qui ça
vous déplaît pas rien de ce qui est
humain ne m'est étranger
ouais c'est ça dos alors même réponse
les deux seaux d'eau seau d'eau vous
l'écrivez comment parce que si c'est
pour avoir un peu d'eau dans la gueule
quand il fait chaud lui voler ses solos
et exhibo j'aimerais j'aimerais bien
être suffisamment bons pour trouver du
plaisir à des gens qui me maintenait
j'ai renoncé à cette vision et j'ai dit
bros ça peut arriver ouais gros lolos
oui je vais trio oui elle était sûre
avec lui et soins trop cynique ou un jeu
vidéo je vous en prie jeu neuf minutes
plus tôt rocco ou chamallows fc mari
d'être chamallows après avoir été rocco
m